is this I don't know what this is it's
really oddly shaped
there's a wax you know what it is
nothing gets me more amped than seeing
good people win lawsuits that they
deserve to win and thank God
h3h3 won their copyright lawsuit which I
was talking about earlier this year the
court has decided in their favor and
[Music]
therefore their style of video critical
commentary creative commentary all of
those things that they do so well are
now further resolved to be part of fair
use judge found that it was a
transformative work he found that their
commentary was quintessential of
creative criticism and the judge decided
that h3h for this video is not a market
substitute
and the judge decided h3 Atreus video is
not a market substitute for the original
video it's not the same thing they both
have different value to offer to the
audience they recognize that it
recognized that it was transformative
they recognized that it had creative
criticism they recognized that they
added something to it and they
recognized that the amount that they
used has no bearing on it being
copyright infringement because the way
that they were commenting on it required
that much use of hostes video in order
to put what they were saying into
context so all of those things have been
recognized it's a huge win and then he
even had the audacity to file a
defamation claim against them which is
outrageous I was gonna talk about it in
the other video that we did and I didn't
talk about it because I thought it was
so far-fetched that not even he would
seek to make a claim like that but he
did and he lost and he lost hard he lost
so hard in fact but the judge decided
all of this on summary judgment motions
now for you non-lawyers out there what
does this mean the judge decided you
know what this doesn't even need to go
to a jury because the evidence presented
by the plaintiff is so weak that no
reasonable juror would find in their
favor ever when you have a hundred and
fifty years or a thousand years of case
precedent and law that all follows the
same line when you have a case that
follows that line that's new the court
doesn't need to bring it in front of a
jury to decide and that's what summary
judgment is it's a really cool mechanism
that the court uses and they used it
here and they nailed it that is
something that h3 h3 didn't touch on in
their video and I think it's super
important because it puts a nail in the
coffin of this case it just further
solidifies it as being in line with all
the other law that's already been
previously decided which is why in their
video they keep harking on how things
were decided as a matter of law oh my
god dude say it again I'm gonna start
telling you to talk dirty to me let me
say whisper matter of law in my ear so
if you haven't seen the videos go watch
them they're pretty great actually I
also wanted to point out most people
would not have fought this and that's
why this is also super
even in hell I made the decision to not
do that they made a decision to stand
their ground and as a result everyone
who makes those kinds of videos benefits
think about that
because he saw trench coat last and so
he's kind of leading what if we
delivered that dialogue at speaking
volume as if they've already made the
decision to start searching so it's not
like a t1 that way it's worth it's more
like a you want that way what what
direction what direction and so it's all
part of that sneaking vibe in this new
new environment okay cool
new york-style dollars right Sam this is
the crazy with the deadly setup I've
ever seen
no it's not I did this I've been doing
this dollar setup for years son I think
we're gonna have to be a human sandbag
blast them from here like down down the
line here we go ready and I don't know
this is it's really oddly shaped sorry I
don't carry a knife like everybody
else's office god I'm tripping I think
like it is really bad right now I've
never sweat this much my whole life it's
one of those mornings where like as I
make breakfast like I see my sweat drip
into the bowl it's all like being under
my chin or on my forehead and I move and
it just goes like and it's about a full
shot it's like an out three these
cereals and just plops into the milk and
that's it yeah you're just sitting there
and dripping into the malkin just to
reconsider their zits smells already
cracker like a bank dude there's a wax
and something's dungeon just in time all
right
sweat the longest distance anyone's ever
gone in the one-wheel I don't know how
long we're opening this mysterious
package
I'm very missable ten miles what is this
it's a cutting board it's the like wood
edging art whoa that Jake so Daniel
day-lewis from there will be blood I
don't want a drip on this that's really
clear these guys are fans of the channel
and they're like would you like some art
intakes like I really like Daniel
day-lewis we should let Jake open this
stuff he's letting you back for a long
time I know but do you do like so much
more hampt about it he was actually
pretty I'm gonna dip out of this segment
I'm dripping out of a WWN grievers
dungeon calm it's like opening your
siblings presents on Christmas yeah this
is a custom artwork right here and it's
still sealed so maybe I will leave this
on his desk time is running out on the
latest quarter digital systems shirt so
if you think you might want one or
anyone else you know does grab one at
corridor digital comm slash store time
is running out
so tactical right now yeah because I
have a lot of my own time career so this
is your own costume right now no this is
everything is theirs except for the vest
belt helmet mass but the rest is that so
pretty much it's like having a feel like
I work at drastic drastic park or
something the last time we had to do
this so last time we had to like
makeshift this really cool hoodie stop
ladies dude I think we did the same
thing for Devil's spear - yep we had to
but we were ready it's all too familiar
dude ready let's keeping it cool
actually cuz on my head first standing
you like being on your handkerchief you
know don't tell me you never peed on
your handkerchief alright good ol Bear
Grylls right how's that yeah we really
like you have more forward
Beasley is my friend guess what I'm
gonna name him friend jr. little lens
capitalist we have a gift for you
it's right here we broke the seal on one
of them because he didn't know what it
was I told you I told you guys what it
was feel like you just really wanted to
open it wait first guys like my chums
yeah they even sealed it with wax yeah
it smells like the renaissance over here
back in the day actually before people
could verify identities in other ways
this was how you gave a signature that's
why families used to have rings where
you could do that and just like put a
seal yeah and what a seal in the wax yep
they also did something very special for
us you know what it is
[Applause]
looks really good
we're would know it's really good corn
our logo there look at the detail in the
burning then all the weapons are
actually like silver yeah
what grade yes you can like see the
detail and look exact same colors same
colors the shirt that no one ever wants
buy yeah so yeah they're not even in the
store anymore what sweet that's a real
solid Waller
my favorite things about the salmon eco
channel now is salts all the cool stuff
we get that we can put on the walls all
the fan art so if you have art and you
want it to be on a wall in our studio
send it to us if you need to ask how to
find our address then shame on you yeah
shame on you speaking of things if
anyone is able to make an oil painting
of this with the text our founder
but that's their dream you can google
that you just type salmon Nico and to
Google let's ask engravers dungeon if
they can make us that but it's gotta be
oil we want something of every medium
we'll need some reliefs and busts as
well yeah I think that marble statue in
about two years guys so huge thanks to
engravers dungeon for sending us this
awesome stuff well I'm gonna put that up
there cuz I got I got that for me I got
that for you guys got that for me
[Music]
Oh